- My advice to young people
is you never want to do
something on the spur of the moment.
And if you say no, me me
me, I I I, nobody likes you.
Anybody that tries to
centralize everything
through themselves or through their staff
really is making a terrible mistake
You can't control how
lucky you are, although
the more you work the luckier you get
You can't just say
something and believe it
You have to be able to show
people that you're right
The most important asset
you have are the people
that leave at night and
come in in the morning
I just don't have anything
in common with people
that sit there and say "Oh
my God, it was terrible."
You're going to spend
your entire life doing
something different than what you think.
Should've, would've and
could've is not a particularly
useful thing to spend your time doing.
This is a world, and I think it's good,
where you don't do anything by yourself.
- He's an American business
magnate, politician
and philanthropist.
He served as the 108th mayor
of New York City serving
for three consecutive
terms with a net worth
of $41 billion, he's the
seventh richest person
in the United States.
He's Michael Bloomberg, and here are
his top ten rules of success.
- You know, I think it's very,
my advice to young people
is you never want to do something
on the spur of the moment
you don't want to jump too
quickly, that doesn't mean
you should sit around
and waste your whole life
and never realize when
something's not going to happen
or when the opportunity's
not going to be presented
but every time I thought about
leaving Solomon I stopped
and said you know I'm learning
a lot, and even though
I might have been able to
make more money elsewhere
it was a great firm.
They were scrupulously honest,
phenomenally competent,
worked very hard, very
nice to me, erm, and, er,
I always decided to stay.
I don't think I ever seriously,
other than maybe a little
Walter Mitty dream now and
then, I don't think I ever
seriously ever thought of
leaving and it turned out to be
great, I'd say nothing but
good things about them,
even when them firing
me was the right thing.
- You never wanted to
beat your competition?
- No, I wanted to be successful
- You said teammates versus competition
- But I mean, at Solomon
Brothers all those times,
you work with other people,
one of the ways incidentally,
Stephanie, to really get
ahead, is to give credit
to somebody else.
When I say oh, I didn't do it,
Lloyd did that and he
involved me, let me tell you,
I'm telling everybody it's
me as well, but I've now
made a friend, and you
respect me because I've shared
the credit, and if you
say, no, me me me, I I I,
nobody likes you and nobody
respects you and they think
you're exaggerating
everything, but to the extent
you've credited someone
else with the thought
of, are they exaggerating?
It doesn't even come up.
And I'm a big delegator in
terms of management style
If you're going to run a 24/7 organization
you have to do that.
Anybody that tries to
centralize everything
through themselves or through their staff
really is making a terrible mistake.
But that's why lots of
businesses don't work
And that's why lots of
governments don't work
Because they do exactly that.
The only thing that you can control
that influences success in life
is how hard you work,
how honest you are, and
how well you deal with others.
You can control those variables.
You can't control how lucky you are
although the more you
work the luckier you get.
You have no influence on the
intellectual capabilities
that God did or did not
give you, but you can
work as hard as possible, you
can be scrupulously honest
so that people respect
you, and you can get along
with others, cos nobody
does anything by themselves.
- Did you have to pay a
price though, you personally?
- Well I think that
everything is an either-or.
There's a price in everything.
You can study or you can go out and play.
You can defer to others or
you can try to hog the credit.
You can be honest and
suffer the consequences,
or you can lie, cheat and
steal, and short-term,
maybe even advance.
But long term, you are better
off if you work harder.
You are better off if you're honest,
and you are better off
if you give others credit
and get them to help you by helping them.
- What do you tell others who
try to strike that balance?
Between family and work
and volunteer efforts
and anything else?
- Well the answer to
either/or is invariably yes,
you can't go all in one direction.
You cannot walk away from
your family for your career.
On the other hand if you
walk away from your career
for your family, you're not
going to have the money to
support the family, and
parents all the time are making
those kinds of choices
between career and family.
They do some of both and
you try to blend the two,
and that may not be the
perfect answer but that's a
practical answer, that I've
always told young people
when they go off to college,
you have to study and
you have to get good
grades, but you certainly
should have a good time as
well because that's part
of your growing-up experience
and there's no point
in leading life to suffer all the time,
you want to enjoy life as
well as the next person,
so some balance, some
blend between the two.
I went to Hopkins to study
physics and it turned
out there was a German
requirement so after 30 days
I became an engineer where
there was no language
requirement.
And I think looking back,
an engineering background
was perhaps the transformative
thing in my life.
Because in science, and it
would have worked if I had
stayed as a physicist too,
I suppose, in science,
you have to be able to
look in the mirror and
answer the question, you
can't just say something
and believe it, you have
to be able to show people
that you're right.
The essence of science
is that somebody else,
independently, can verify
what you claim you saw.
And that discipline of not just taking
people's word for it, or not
just automatically falling in
to what's generally accepted,
has forced me to step back
and say why?
And to question.
And if you question
why we're doing things,
I think you'll find yourself
targeting your energies
much more efficiently,
appropriately, and in a much
more satisfying way.
So somebody says well this works,
well that may be, but
you know, stop and think,
does it make any common sense?
Listen to what people
are telling you to do.
Think about what they
say in the newspaper,
does it make any sense?
Do you want to be part of it?
Could you do it better?
It's that mental
discipline of questioning,
which I guess is the scientific method.
- What do you think has
mattered about the culture
of Bloomberg?
And what lessons do you
think a company like this
should learn?
- I think it's not just for companies
I think it's for governments
and everybody else.
People want recognition and respect.
And whether you do it
by giving them free food
and nice offices, whether
you do it by always
giving them the credit
when somebody says why
does it go along?
I always make a point when
I walk into a building
I shake the hands of the
security people at the door.
If it wasn't for them, the
rest of us wouldn't be able
to go in and conduct our business.
They're just as important
as the head of the company.
I think we have too many
distinctions between
people and the egalitarian
concept that America
was built around, I think, really works.
And at Bloomberg I abolished all titles
there's no titles in the company.
On my card, it never said anything,
it just said Michael
Bloomberg, and address,
and phone number.
In those days you didn't
even have email addresses,
today they continue with that process.
Everybody knows who they work for,
there is a hierarchy, you
have to have a hierarchy,
you have to have structure,
but that doesn't mean
that we should have, every
time we introduce somebody,
something that distinguishes
and says that one person
is more important than the other.
In city government you can't quite do that
because they're built
into the structure is
different, and the
requirements they use titles
is different, but in the
private sector to the extent
that you can include
everybody in this room and
around the world that works
for Google, I would argue,
do it, that's what we do at Bloomberg.
To the extent that you
can make people be happy
to come to work and want to be there,
in the end luck plays
a very important part
in how successful you are,
but the harder you work,
and the longer you work, the
luckier you're going to be.
So you want people to want to
come in early in the morning
and want to stay late.
You want people that, if they
want to take some time off
for family obligations that's fine,
but you want them to want to come back,
and I think if you take a look,
you're never going to please everybody.
Bloomberg has about 9,500 employees,
maybe 120 offices around the world,
and there'll always be
somebody that isn't happy.
But fundamentally we have
a very low turnover rate,
and I think whenever you
have intellectual content
as the basis of your business,
and certainly Google does,
and certainly Bloomberg does,
the most important asset
you have are the people that
leave at night and come in
in the morning.
And so that's where your focus should be.
- And what's your advice to these small
business founders today?
- Work hard, you're
going to need some luck,
but the harder you work,
the luckier you get.
And if it doesn't work out,
it's not the end of the world.
I just don't have anything
in common with people
that sit there and say "Oh
my God, it was terrible."
It's water over the dam, under
the bridge, get on with it
and start another business the next day,
or another career, and be
honest, look in the mirror,
and say why didn't it work out?
Well it wasn't the skillset,
or it wasn't I didn't have
the temperament for it, or
I was in the wrong place,
wrong time, maybe I can
afford to do it again,
maybe I can't, but people
aren't honest with themselves.
What I've always done is
I've taken a yellow pad,
I've drawn a line down the middle,
write out the pros on one
side, the cons on another,
in the sense that if I let
you see it, you wouldn't
laugh at me.
And then when I get done, I
just rip it up and throw it
away because I've worked out in my mind,
What is real, and what
isn't and what I can
present to people and what I can't.
And this goes back to my boy
scout days, is be prepared.
I know what you're thinking, you're
already prepared, you've mapped
out the rest of your life,
the rest of your education,
postgraduate work,
residencies, fellowships,
clerk ships, and you're
going to have a long, meaningful career.
You have all of your
plans already laid down.
That's not the preparation
I'm talking about,
because let me tell you
the likelihood of you
winding up 10 years from
now doing what you think
you're going to be
doing ten years from now
is probably less than one in ten.
The truth of the matter is, you don't know
what opportunities are
going to be presented
to you, you don't know where
you're going to succeed
and where you're going
to fail, the careers that
you wind up in are invariably
going to be very different
so what I would do is I
would focus on how I interact
with people, how I approach
problems, I would get involved
in government, if you want
to go into public service,
I would recommend you first
become a billionaire but
that's another issue.
You're going to spend your
entire life doing something
different than what you
think, and the good news is
that Dartmouth is preparing
you for that, because
while you think there are
individual subjects, what
they're really teaching you
to do is to think and to
reason and to build relationships,
and that's what's going
to carry you.
- Well from the book, after
you were fired or let go
from Solomon, "I didn't sit
around wondering what was
"happening at the old firm,
I didn't go back and visit,
"I never look over my
shoulder, once finished, gone,
"life continues."
Yes, you can't sit there,
and should've, would've
and could've is not a
particularly useful thing
to spend your time doing.
It will just leave you
heartsick, or it'll leave
you living a past life
and not looking towards what
could be great tomorrow.
- How important is it
to have salesmanship,
you could have the best idea in the world?
- I don't know any business
where sales isn't a big
part of it, or cooperation
and collaboration isn't
a big part of it, I suppose
if you're a monk and have
a vow of silence, maybe,
but an author, for example,
you've got to work with an
editor, you've got to talk
to a publisher, and you have
to deal with your family.
And it's, they're all, this
is a world, and I think
it's good, where you don't
do anything by yourself.
Nobody just works for one
person or just works for
themselves, nobody does
anything independently,
we deal, and whether it's
your family, your outside
life, your business life, or whatever
- Thank you guys so much
for watching, I made
this video because Will C
asked me to, so if there's
a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments
below, I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know which
of Michael Bloomberg's
top ten rules meant the
most to you, what's going to
have the biggest impact on
your life, on your business,
leave it in the comments
during the discussion.
Thank you guys so much
for watching, continue
to believe, and I'll see you soon.
- What would you like
to see as your legacy?
- What would you like to
say that you achieved with
your life?
- Well I think I'd want my
kids to look back and say
he was a great mayor, and
honest, and made a big
difference in the city,
but I think the things
that will last are things
like the life expectancy
numbers or the economic
development of New York City
compared to other cities,
or reforming education,
which is always a two-step
forward, one-step back thing,
but if we can be an impetus
to Rahm Emanuel, for example,
to stand up and fight for
the control of the school
system in Chicago, or
elsewhere around the country,
I think those would be good legacies.
If we could figure out a
way to stop this carnage
from illegal guns, that
would be another thing,
but if you go back, go down
the road and look back,
those are the kinds of things,
investment in educational
institutions, my alma mater,
Johns Hopkins, that you're
on the board of, or Harvard,
where one of my daughters
went to graduate school,
and I did, or Princeton,
and NYU, those universities will, I hope,
make a difference in the
world and I'll be a little
part of it.
At Hopkins we have a malaria
project, for example,
trying to build a better mosquito.
And the reason, you want
a mosquito that's tougher
than the others that
doesn't carry the malaria
parasite, and then it
would drive out the others.
It's really probably the
only ways to stop malaria
which kills a couple of
million people every year.
When our Nobel Prize
winner who runs the project
wins his second Nobel Prize,
and I've challenged him
to do so, I'll have a
little bit of that prize,
'cause I helped fund it,
and so will the clinicians,
and other scientists that work with him,
and so will patients that work with him.
We don't do anything on
our own, and everybody
collaborates and gets
something from somebody else.
And I also hope that I'll
set a standard and that
whoever comes after me will
be a better mayor than I am.
I'm going to live in New York
City and I've always, in my life
tried to hire people smarter than me.
I've certainly done that with
my deputy mayors in the city,
the people that are running
Bloomberg, and hopefully the
public will pick a successor
that will turn out to be,
nobody'll ever think anybody is
at the beginning, but will
turn out to be a better mayor
and will take it forward.
And I hope that Washington
gets its act together
and starts understanding,
we are in trouble
in this country.
Niall Ferguson wrote a
great story about the end
of civilizations and how
quickly things can collapse.
Rome in a couple of decades,
the USSR in a couple of years.
I mean that was the second
biggest power in the world
and two years, it's gone.
We really are on a cliff, and
it's not just the fiscal cliff
we're already over the fiscal
cliff, the question is,
are we going to pull a rip
cord or just keep falling?
But we're on a cliff socially, as well.
And the world is not
necessarily on our side.
- Did you ever think your
company wasn't going to make it,
in the early years?
Were you nervous it
wasn't going to make it?
- Sure.
For the first year,
it's always an exciting
thing, every two weeks
I wrote another check
to the company from my
personal bank account,
to put money in to pay the help.
And the last year of the
three that it took me
to get customers, you
could see that that light
at the end of the tunnel wasn't a train
coming towards you, it
really was that you were
going to get out of this
and it was going to work.
The middle year, what you
find is that your family
and your friends say,
you know, I know you know
what you're doing and I have
all that confidence in ya,
but you know just in case,
because we were competing
against big companies, and
every article in the paper
said this was foolish, you
can't win against big companies,
I've always thought that
competing against big companies
for a small company is not
only exciting, it is, it has
enormous potential, because
big companies never believe
the little company is going
to challenge them until
it's too late, and big companies
have such an infrastructure
and investment, and product
and people and brands, and
that sort of thing, that they
can't change, and you know,
Clay Christensen's Disruptive
Technologies, if you need
more examples of that taking
place just pick up the paper.
Every day there's another
industry going out of business.
The other day we gave
awards to ten different
small startup companies.
Our economic development corporation did.
In the fashion industry.
And I'm talking to this guy,
what did he get an award from?
He has a computer program,
you just stand in front
of his camera, turn around
once, and then he has your
body measurements for every
single square inch of you
down to a science.
That goes straight to the loom,
and the next set of jeans
that comes off is built
perfectly for your body.
Think about how many people in the process
that's going to take out.
That's one of the great
challenges for creating new jobs
that that kind of technology
takes away a lot of the
kinds of things.
But there is still the demand
for people creating that
kind of program, there's
still demand for the designer
who comes up with what's
fashionable or not.
So there is potential, but
it requires investment in
infrastructure and it
requires better education
than we are providing our kids today with.
And it requires people from
around the world wanting to
come here, rather than sending
these industries overseas.